this is a production of cornell
university
thank you so much john it's really um
it's an honor to be here with all of you
today you may have noticed a couple of
furry beings that may come in and out of
my screen so
um i'm i'm at home uh right now
broadcasting
live from downtown ithaca um and so i'm
here with my cat so please excuse their
uh interruptions but
we'll try not to let them get too much
in the way so i wanna um
begin i think with with any uh start of
any any
work that we do here at cornell um to
remember the condition of possibility
for all of us to be here living and
learning
on the ithaca campus and beyond um
cornell university
is located on the traditional homelands
of the gaia kono the kyuga nation
um they're members of the honest
confederacy an alliance of six sovereign
nations with both historic
and contemporary presence on this land
um this is a long
and painful history of dispossession
that of course for those of you who have
been following
um the recent news uh the
story that broke really last march on
about the moral act and the land grab
noting that cornell is one of the
largest the largest beneficiary of
expropriated indigenous lands so in
addition to being here on guyakono
uh homelands and territory uh you can
see in this
uh map that cornell university also
as part of the scripts that ezra cornell
obtained um
through the moral act uh obtained almost
a million acres of expropriated
indigenous land
um and in addition to that uh cornell
owns 420
000 acres mineral rights on 100 420
000 acres of indigenous lands in central
and southwestern
united states which isn't depicted on
this map but my colleagues in the
american indian and indigenous studies
program are working very hard
to try to understand all of
this better and sharing that information
with the public so i hope you'll
if you're curious i hope you are you'll
learn more by
following the blog um which the link is
at the
bottom and i'm happy to share these
slides too at the end of my
presentation i also want to acknowledge
the fact that any work um that we do
creatively it involves a lot of people
and a lot of collaborations
um so back in 2015 uh my first year at
cornell was the 2014-2015
school year i came in as an assistant
professor
and i was asked to teach a course on
textile surface design
and while i practiced it in my own
creative practice and you know had taken
courses during my undergraduate
i sort of had to re-train myself in this
field and so i began working at that
time with a number of
different faculty students both at
cornell and other universities
local artists as well to found this
natural dye studio
so there are many many people involved
in the work that i'm going to share with
you today
i want to particularly acknowledge my
now
graduated phd student in the upper left
kelsey doty
she just finished her phd last year and
i'm pleased to say it has a faculty
position at kansas state
which she began this fall she
and i really collaborated very closely
on on many different projects that i'll
be sharing with you today
in addition to a number of our other
students that have gone on to do amazing
things
um in the center is the instagram page
of blossom schmidt
she's a cal's graduate a couple of think
2017
she went on to actually start her own
naturally dyed
clothing company uh rachel powell in the
upper right she's now a fashion designer
for free people
starting to incorporate natural dyes
into the larger apparel supply chain um
and on the bottom right uh kennedy rau
and rachel quang um kennedy now in
graduate school rachel
is working in the fashion industry and
so there's just been a lot of
you know the wonderful thing about
working with students they come
and then they go and then they go and do
amazing things and so there's a
wonderful network of folks that have
been part of this project and i'd like
to acknowledge them at the beginning
so today i'm going to take you through
you know very quickly
to understand what are natural dyes
right any plant animal fungus or mineral
that can be used for coloration of fiber
um and then to ask the question right
what natural
colorants come to mind um i think anyone
who's gotten
you know beet juice on their clothing or
has experienced
stains from cooking turmeric
others you might have some ideas of of
plants that can be used for coloration
so i want to think about plant dyes in
terms of cultivation
management and waste so we can think
about cultivation
by considering dye gardens or plants
that you can include in your
garden out front i live in downtown
ithaca south plain street
and my entire front yard is very tiny
but i've been able to get a lot of dye
plants in there
um we can also think about management of
really aggressive
and and invasive species and you all are
the experts on this so i would love to
think about
in the future right could we collaborate
together on thinking about management of
of different kinds of plants and then of
course there's waste
um oops uh waste
food waste agricultural waste industrial
waste how can we divert waste
um and then use it for something
beneficial in this case
thinking about natural dyes so in 2015
um
i worked with our alumni affairs and
development office and my colleagues in
the
college of human ecology facilities um
one of my it's i just actually about an
hour before this presentation
learned that um one of my colleagues in
our facility depart facilities
department just passed away
and his name is jeff serene and he um
did an amazing job was an incredible
advocate early on i show up
you know all bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed and like want to take over
space
you know and my colleagues were so
wonderful
in helping me to realize the vision that
i had which was
to create a dye garden of course there's
an amazing dye garden at the botanic
gardens
uh which you can go you can see the dye
plants but you can't harvest them it's
curated right so
i wanted to create a space where we'd be
able to grow cultivate plants and then
harvest them and use them
in our creative production and our
classes as well as independent projects
and so uh my my dear and wonderful
colleagues in the college of human
ecology facilities department
worked with me to identify a space and
this is in the courtyard between
martha van rensleer hall and the human
ecology building
and then um pam shade at the botanic
garden she was very kind at the
beginning of the season to give me
um some of the matter root it's a very
aggressive plant so she was able to give
me some some of their dyers chamomile
from the botanic gardens and so
coming together i worked with our alumni
affairs department to
uh to do a crowd funding campaign so we
could raise some funds to buy things
like shovels and hoses
and you know uh compost to amend the
soil
and so this is what it looked like that
first year
um and of course i worked with students
with 4hrs
whoever was interested and we planted
this garden you can see some purple
basil in the upper left and some
marigolds in the bottom right
and eventually um this was actually the
first site
that we had for the dye garden was
actually on the terrace level so for one
year we we did it out there
which was very beautiful but for a
number of reasons we decided to move it
to the courtyard it would be a little
easier
one important reason is that actually
you can't get into these beds
um if you've ever been to the human
ecology building they
they actually there's a very very steep
uh
drop on the other side so it made it
very hard to harvest
safely from this place you actually had
to get roped in to go into the bed so
we decided to change the location but
this was the this was actually the very
first year in 2015.
and so you can see um we grow hopi dye
sunflowers which also has this added
benefit of creating a little bit of
shade
for our all glass skinned building at
least for the first level
of the building every every august of
course during the height of summer
so it's got that nice sort of built-in
benefit one day i'd like to do all of
the
um parts of the the garden um and we
grow
uh a lot of marigolds cosmos double flag
yellow irises this was a year when you
can see that the
prior year the marigolds weren't
thriving so much um here they are
thriving and of course they're wonderful
because you know the more you pop those
heads off
the longer they'll go and so you can
really get beautiful color it's a
beautiful looking garden but it's also
producing
a lot of material for dye throughout the
year and just a few more images
on the bottom right that's japanese
indigo which we've also
grown with more or less success over the
years
uh dyer's chamomile on the right there
and then we also um used our fabrication
studio downstairs to etch
laser etch these signs that we are able
to put in the garden so that people can
understand what it is that they're
seeing
in this space so we can also think about
um
management right or just the the dyes
that are all around us
that maybe we're not thinking about
acorns
what can you gather right that's fallen
to the ground things like black walnut
halls of course a really wonderful
source of dye
invasive species like purple loose
strife for example
or things like goldenrod that are
growing really really voraciously
and then of course there are food waste
dyes so um
kelsey doughty my phd student she worked
directly with cornell dining to divert
food waste for a couple of years and we
were able to use things like yellow
onion skins you see here
onion skins create beautiful beautiful
dye and i'll show you later but i
brought a few things this is what onion
skins look like
if you can see my video when they're eco
printed or contact dyed onto
fabric as well so you can sometimes even
retain some of the
texture and the line that comes with the
onion skin or you can do a vat dye where
you get a more solid color like on the
right
of course red onion skins work too and
yield a slightly different color
avocado pits are another great source of
dye
they yield a really beautiful kind of
dusty
rose um the water the soak water from
dried black beans is also another
wonderful
source of dye i often use it it's very
almost like a lightish blue
i tend to use it to over dye a lot of
things this is just a little bit of a
silk that i had printed
and then over dyed it's a really nice
color and this of course isn't
an exhaustive list and i'm just sharing
with you a few examples
but you can think about things like
pomegranate skins carrot tops coffee
grounds
teas beets concord grapes um
berries berries tend to be a less stable
dye but you can still get color
understanding sometimes that that color
may shift or will shift and change over
time
so then what do you do with all this
stuff once you've cultivated it
um so i titled this talk techniques
you're dying to know
and so i'm going to help you think
through some of the different techniques
that one might use after you've
you know collected all of this material
or grown the plants yourself
how do you prepare your fabric for dye
how do you achieve the best color
fastness or
how do you understand the ways that the
colors will shift
so we tend to think and the fashion
industry has of course produced and
perpetuated this idea that color has to
be stable
and this of course has to do with
factory production
and ensuring consistency but what if our
clothes did change color over time what
if we just
practiced re-dying once something
started to shift
and change what if we embrace the change
that could come with
uh the uncertainty and variability
that natural dyes present to us so i
think
philosophically we could ask some of
these like larger questions and it's
interesting to think about color
fastness of course
is uh the way that the color is retained
over time
exposure to light washing water
abrasion these things are going to
affect
the color um and cause it to fade over
time so we want to try to prevent that
but at the same time
you know on the other hand we may want
to embrace it in different ways too
as as designers and as wearers and
consumers
and then there are of course different
dying and color transfer techniques some
of which are more
sustainable than others and you know i
wanna
i wanna make sure that you don't walk
away from this presentation
thinking necessarily that natural dyes
are the end all be
all like sustainable solution because
they're not they're often a lot more
water intensive
um they require require mortens which
we'll talk about in just a second
and um you know so there are issues
and issues around scalability of these
dyes that we still have to work through
and overcome but we can work towards
more sustainable solutions and that's my
hope
okay so to understand what to do with
all this stuff we also have to
understand
fibers so what are the different fiber
types you can we typically
classify them as either protein
cellulosic or synthetic
and so protein fibers are of course what
you're seeing
on the left are the the cocoons
silkworm cocoons um i love this image
this was uh circulating on the internet
a few years back it was a sheep that had
escaped and was like living in a cave
for years and years and so hadn't
been um sheared and so had
developed into this giant uh puffball
but of course
sheep are typically sheared uh once a
year so we have sheep's wool
fur of different kinds human hair these
are all protein
fibers a spider silk also a protein
fiber
and then we have cellulosic fibers
things like cotton
linen flax hemp jute and then
technically the man-made fiber known as
viscose or rayon
tencel these are what are called
regenerated cellulosic fibers so they're
man-made fibers but they come from wood
pulp essentially
um so a lot of people have you know
there's a lot of talk about bamboo
over the last few years as being more
sustainable well yes
it does grow very quickly but in fact
the processing
of bamboo and wood pulp generally to
make it to
to get the viscosity needed um for the
fiber
actually does a lot of harm to the
environment so again nothing is black or
white you all know this
uh working in this area i'm sure
and then of course there's the
synthetics but what i
i want you to come away with this
knowing is that really it's only nylon
that can
readily take natural dyes people are
working on
polyesters and other types of synthetic
fibers to try to increase
its ability or find ways for it to take
dye and remain color fast but
as it stands nylon is very similar in
its
chemistry to silk and so nylon will
actually take natural dyes
and when i talk about the yoga clothes a
little bit later
um i'm typically working with nylons
um that do have a spandex blend but
and of course the spandex blend is not
taking the color
so again this is depending on the blend
uh the percentages we can kind of guess
how
deep and vibrant the color will be
okay so now that we know a little bit
about the fiber types
we need different dyes for different
fiber types
um and we'll talk about this how this
plays out in natural dyes
in a bit but what's important to know
that textile coloration
and dyeing is estimated to use over 378
billion liters of water per year
in this processing depending how well
it's regulated or not we can see
that the release of toxic chemicals um
into waterways
and the destruction of ecosystems and
um and and the like throughout uh
many many parts of the world um
responsible for up to one-fifth of
industrial water police
pollution and i've read in a number of
different places that
uh textile dying is considered the
second largest polluter of water in the
world so it's it's a
pretty intense and damaging industry
in addition to the dye process though
there are a number of other
things that happen to fiber and textiles
that also cause
water pollution and this table is just
giving you a little bit of a sense of
that
um singing for example you're like
what's singeing
when you when you uh weave
say a cotton textile together for
example there's all these like fuzzy
edges and so the the textile actually
goes through a process where it is
it goes through essentially fire where
it singes off all those sort of
extra fibers a cotton is a staple fiber
which means that many fibers are spun
together so you end up with the little
edges sticking out
de-sizing for example removing starch
all of these bleaching
in order to prepare the fabric for dye
so you can get that consistent color
all of these processes use water and
they may contribute to
pollution obviously of that same water
so when we think about sustainable ideas
for textile coloration we can think
about for example low chemical bleaching
or no bleaching but again
because of the fashion industry and and
the need for
consistency bleaching is pretty
pretty integral to the process and so
can we think about ways to do more low
impact low chemical bleaching
low impact dyeing creating colors
without dyeing
for example fox fiber so cotton fibers
that are naturally colored
it has been a struggle to develop those
because the staple length is typically
much shorter
and so when you have a shorter staple
length and you spin those fibers
together you end up with a weaker yarn
but you know folks in your area are
working on this
right now which i think is really
exciting there's also ways in which you
can solution dye polyester for example
so this is
a you know polyester we think of as
being you know
not environmentally friendly it's a
petroleum by-product
that is all true on the other hand
polyester is one of the
best uh environmentally when you and
when it comes to textile coloration
because you can actually
dye the the polyester solution before
it's spun out of the spinneret into a
fiber so again
there's you know weighing the pros and
the cons and of course then natural dyes
which
we're talking about today so with
natural dyes
um you often need something called a
mordant
to improve its performance you have both
substantial
natural dyes which are direct dyes these
are dyes like indigo
which are going to bond right away with
the fiber you do not need
a chemical bridge to enable the dye and
fiber molecules to bond
substantive dyes are great indigo is one
of them
um tyrion purple from the mollusk that's
another one that is a direct dye
a substantial dye but for the most part
part most plant dyes
um are going to require a mordant and
are called adjective natural dyes
and even so with some of the more direct
dyes
arguably black walnut is a direct dye
you can you know it'll bond with the
fiber however
if you want to increase the depth of the
color or you want to enhance color
fastness you would also need to have a
mordent
and natural dyes as i mentioned work
best with natural textiles
with the exception of course being nylon
so there are so many color possibilities
uh with natural dyes but what you must
have
is patience uh creative problem solving
uh time for trial and error
and a willingness to accept the
challenge of
irreproducibility or attempts at
reproducibility can be really
frustrating of course because
depending on the growing conditions um
the you know the matter you have this
year might be different from the matter
you had last year or different from
matter that was grown in india
versus what we grew in the human ecology
building so
um there are a lot of variables that you
have to navigate in this process so it
does require a lot of patience
but it's really fulfilling and rewarding
to create
such a range of colors
so in order to get the color that you
want the the way to set yourself up for
success
begins with what's called um scouring
um so scouring is the process of washing
so for any of you that are sewers you
know the first thing you do with your
fabric when you get it
you wash it and then you sew it you
don't want to sew it first and then
throw what you sewed into the washing
machine you know that shrinkage will
occur
but in the case of natural dyes we
really want to remove
any sizing a lot of of fabrics when they
they come out of the factory
there's some kind of sizing that's been
put on them or other kinds of finishes
dirt grime oils whatever it might be
it's a deep a scouring is a deep
penetration and cleaning of the fabric
with both heat and soap different fibers
uh
can take heat in different ways so for
example silk is very delicate you do not
want to
boil uh your silk fiber you're going to
ruin the hand
ruin the quality of it whereas with
other fibers like cotton it can take
a lot of that heat and actually in some
ways is better because you can then get
the
the textile shrunk down to the size that
it will ultimately be
after washing scouring enables you to
have equal penetration of dye so you get
a more even color
and again methods of scattering will
depend on the type of fiber
you're not going to put a silk into a
boiling
or very very high heat wash for example
so then we have the next step which is
the mordanting process
mordent in the english language
is an adjective we use if you remember
from your sat vocabulary lists
as an adjective to describe something or
somebody
who might be sort of cruel biting
sarcastic
and in the romance languages it also
means to bite
um so it comes from the latin morder to
bite
and it enables essentially the dye
molecule to bite
uh the fiber molecule so it creates that
bridge it fixes the dye to your material
it's going to improve light fastness
color fastness
prevent color bleeding and then
different mordants
will have different kinds of brightening
and color changing effects as well
so there are sort of two things
happening here one it's ensuring color
fastness
and two uh the mordant can have
an effect on the color change um in the
example that you're looking at here
this is a concord grape skin dye
um a relatively unstable dye so you know
in four or five years this textile is
going to look a lot more faded
this is the the way with barry dies
sadly but um
what's the effect that's been used here
was a manipulation of the ph
um so you can see uh what happens when
you have a more acidic or alkaline after
wash
you'll see that squiggle right down the
center
so mortens and i'm happy to provide all
of you i don't know if you have a shared
box folder for this seminar but i'm
happy to provide you with
specific mordenting instructions for
each of the fiber types this is probably
one of the more laborious aspects of
this
it takes you know four to 12 hours
usually
for a mordent bath to complete
for protein fibers and nylon we use
aluminum sulfate
at about 12 weight of fiber so you weigh
your fiber dry
after you've scoured it and then you
calculate what 12
of that weight is and that's the amount
of um
of the morning that you'll need um in
this case we're looking at metallic
salts are most commonly used
uh for that pre-mordant bath for
cellulosic fibers we use aluminum
acetate that's a very successful
um mordant of course there are a lot of
different morning recipes these are my
personal favorites that i'm sharing with
you
um and usually you allow your textiles
to steep in the morning bath and you
also want enough space
for the textile to move around so if you
have a lot of textile in a tiny pot
right it's not going to have that free
movement i have used
bathtubs for morning ting i've used
washing machines you can use a lot of
different things but you want to have
the space for the textile to move around
so you can ensure that you have an equal
distribution of the mordant
because if part of the textile mortens
and then say there was a fold or
you know hadn't gotten moved around and
a part of the textile didn't quite take
up the mordant
you're going to end up with uneven color
so i want to um ensure the that
everybody
of course stays safe in the practice of
natural dyes
natural uh doesn't mean non-toxic
as you all know there are many plants
that are toxic
and while aluminum acetate and aluminum
sulfate are both uh
relatively considered fairly non-toxic
uh they are powder and so
if you're not working under a fume hood
and you're you know scooping aluminum
acetate into you know your pyrex
container before you pour the
boiling water on it's there it's it's a
soft powder it could be easily inhaled
and so it really
you know doesn't matter what it is
you're inhaling it's bad for your lungs
so please
always wear a mask especially when
you're handling these
mordants and keep in mind of course that
some plants are also
toxic and so always wearing gloves
and a mask is advised
mordants can also damage fiber over time
so
one of the mordants that we often use um
so there i i should have added a slide
to say there are kind of three methods
of mordanting either pre-morten ting
which is what i most commonly do more
than the fabric first
and then you're kind of good to go you
can screen print it you could bundle it
you could do a lot of different things
um there's also mortising mordanting
that can happen
simultaneously with a vat so if you're
say
creating a single that of color you
could put the morton in the vat and
and be mordanting and coloring the
textile at the same time this of course
only works
if you want a solid color or maybe
you're doing some kind of resist dying
and then there's post-mortem ting and
post-smordanting is really about
manipulating color change um as well so
so with iron for example it tends to
uh satin colors that's the uh technical
term it's saturn's colors
um so it might take for example a bright
magenta and saturn it to
a uh you know a sort of purple or
um kind of a gray purple for example
iron was often added uh in in the
production of calicos
and different um printed textiles in the
18th and 19th centuries
um to get really dark dark color and so
a lot of times if you look at say these
are some old quilts these are just from
my house
these are some 19th century quilts and
you can see that the polka dots on the
left
every little tiny black polka dot is
gone and has been replaced by the
absence of
of that fiber because literally the iron
morning
that was used to create that deep dark
black polka dot
has um has disintegrated the iron has
caused the fabric
and fiber to damage over time you can
see the same thing we call it iron rot
on the right side
so very quickly uh you know
we natural dies have been around a long
time um
and it's important to remember right we
look at this egyptian sock for example
um or you know when we look at
historical art we know the importance of
the color purple tyree and purple the
phoenicians trading this
this really valuable mollusk um the
calico print fabrics that we see
and we just talked about in the last
slide it really wasn't until 1856 until
william henry perkins
accidentally synthesized the aniline dye
you know trying to to figure out
something else in his chemistry lab but
um ended up with mauve which becomes a
very popular color
in fashion in the late 19th century and
and really since 1856
up until really recently there there was
almost a complete abandonment of natural
dyes
even the synthesis of for example indigo
so much of the indigo that's used for
denim today is a synthetic form of
indigo
really quickly i'm going to go through a
number of different dye plants because
just to give you a sense this is not an
exhaustive list
but some of the things that we grow in
our garden we grow mata root
again the part of the plant we use is
the root um in this case not the leaves
some of the plants we use the leaves not
the roots so
it's important to know what part of the
dye you you use
we see matter historically uh on what
remains you know textiles obviously
they degrade especially the natural
textiles so
they don't tend to survive the
archaeological record like some other
materials do but we can see these
examples
matter was used for the british redcoats
though the higher ranked officers
actually used cochineal which
is the scale insect um
marigold a really wonderful plant to use
and to grow in this region
cosmos another wonderful
vibrant plant we use for the the petals
same with with marigolds we use the
the petals of the flower um hopi
dye sunflowers we can grow in this
region as well as you saw
in the earlier images and we actually
use the hull of the sunflower seeds so
you can also
experiment with black oil sunflower
seeds you can buy those giant 40 pound
bird seed bags at agway if you wanted to
experiment with that
it's going to yield kinds of purple
indigo of course
most people know indigo this is an image
when i was in india with my students a
few years ago visiting indigo dyers
this dye is is non-toxic hence it's
fine for her hands to be like this and
and she was um
the woman was explaining to us how proud
she was to be an indigo dyer and the way
that it was revealed on
her hands
all right and then this is just a little
video um
from the india trip that i took and you
can see the way that that is
um it's very much alive and the vats are
in the ground
i could spend an entire lecture talking
about
indigo alone but it's it's a pretty
amazing
dye commonly known we know it in our
blue jeans but again much of the indigo
that's used today is a synthetic version
we can grow japanese indigo in this
region and
we have if you see it flowering like
this that's bad news for the dye
gardener though because
we really want to harvest it right
before it blooms
alcanet another really wonderful dye of
course we have tree dyes as well
osage orange um we use
we can use that that's the again one way
i say tree dye
not the leaves but the the actual uh
wood of the tree
um henna as well people know henna for
the the beautiful work
um on hands and you know
body but it can also be used for
textiles of course skin
is a we'll take dye too black walnut
another one from around this region log
wood very toxic
so be careful but yields wow such an
incredible purple
so i want to spend the rest of the time
talking about some of the techniques and
and i hope that this will inspire you to
experiment because it's really all about
experimentation so probably the easiest
way to create a natural dyes of that dye
and uh indigo is on the left there
that's its sort of own
um own and very complex uh
production to get a really solid indigo
bat but for most of the other natural
dyes that come from plants it's
essentially like making a giant
bat of tea um and so the good news is
that you can save
marigolds like we were talking about
earlier you know the more you pop their
heads off the more they'll bloom
um and so what we do is we have to just
have like big screens
uh like like screens from uh from your
window
and we lay them out across tables in our
studio and human ecology building we
just like lay out the flowers and let
them dry out so that we have this uh
it's a great way to save the flowers and
then you can rehydrate them
and that dies later on this technique is
best for designs that require solid
colors
because it involves usually complete
submersion of your textile into the vat
and what's important to note is that you
try to remove all the plant matter
before you submerge your textiles so it
doesn't get
sort of caught up in in your fiber
um this is a short little video of
swatched sample tests in one of my
classes
where we created you know 10 different
bats of dye
and each student you know is keeping
track of what kind of mordant was used
in the tag on the swatch um and
different kinds of um
effects in the in the dye bath as well
so they all have to make swatch
books like recipe books essentially for
my textile design class
so you can get a sense here right this
is matter for example this was a student
project they wanted to look at the
difference between wool silk and cotton
whether they were you know using heat or
just regular tap water
what happens when you add lemon juice to
make it more acidic
what happens when you add soda ash to
make it more alkaline
how does this affect the color and so
you can see from the same
you know this is the same starting
material the matter
um we can get this really wide range of
colors on different types of fibers
and then of course when you you know
have solid color you can then
design it in different ways so on the
left is rachel powell
um this was all uh raw silk that she had
dyed in a lot of different natural dye
baths
and then had sewn it all together and on
the right is
matthew seaman he was a plant science
major actually
and the backdrop to the screen printed
design the screen printing that he did
was acrylics but the um that yellow that
he created was from
an onion skin bath and then of course
with that you can also do really
interesting um
resist techniques in japan it's called
shibori
in india it's called bondini or in the
u.s we might just call it tie-dye right
different ways of tying and creating
compression to the fiber
and then dyeing it so you can see this
is called mokume in the middle
this is a kind of running stitch that
you do in rows alongside each other at
the very end you pull all the stitches
super tight
you can also fold textiles um to create
different kinds of prints i'll show you
some examples later on
and then this is chenky
randorf she was an mfa student who
worked with us in the natural dye studio
for a couple of years
um and you can see some of her work um
inspired by
uh yoruba indigo dyers and their
techniques
and then of course we can use another
kind of resist um known as batik
uh batik is typically wax but you can
also use
uh there's rice paste resist or cassava
root resist
but it's basically um in this case with
batik wax batik you
you put hot wax onto the fiber or fabric
and it prevents um it creates a resist
so the the dye can no longer penetrate
that area of the fabric
and then you end up with these beautiful
kinds of crackles so you can see some
students in my classes and their
indigo work with um with batik
and this is some of my work this is
actually this is this is the textile
right here i tried to set up so you can
see it although it's a little bit
backlit
this is actually wax um hot wax that i
just sort of flung onto the textile um
if i were to do this again i would
definitely have uh
flung a little more carefully because
cleaning up hot wax is not fun but
um it really ended up with this uh this
effect that i
i was trying to go for this sort of like
wave like
um impact and so that's indigo at the
very bottom of the hem
um is that same makume technique that
uses turmeric and
matter roots so it was first dyed with
turmeric then i
stitched it pulled it tightly dyed it
with matter roots you can die
over and over again you don't have to
re-mordant
between each die bath you can keep over
dying
and then the dress that she's wearing is
made of turmeric and then indigo at the
top and the bottom and then the binding
is all tumeric as well
this is another outfit that i made that
combines some of these resist techniques
um the jacket
was folded and clamped and then the top
here this is again the
batik so i first dyed it with turmeric
then i put on a
just a covering of wax and then dyed it
with indigo
and up here that's madder root that then
was over dyed with indigo
you can also create paint so once you
pre-morten your textile
um the one on the left is actually
cochineal so that's not a plant dye but
um but the la the purple that you see
here is actually logwood
um this was one of my students uh grace
lawson and she did this beautiful
magnolia silk painting so with silk
painting you use a kind of
gutta which creates a resist um
and gutta uh basically enables you to do
watercolors within
shapes so all of these white lines are
the gutter resist
so as long as you put the dye in there
it shouldn't hop over the edge of that
resist it should stay contained in that
area so you can get this really
beautiful brilliant watercolor effects
and really what you're doing is you're
taking concentrated dyes so you either
would take you know all those marigold
flowers or all those black walnuts and
really boil them down until you get a
concentrate or you buy a concentrate
a natural dye concentrate and and just
mix it with water
um and sometimes requiring heat other
times not
different mordants can again change the
color and then you can really get this
beautiful paint
painterly effect and you can see another
one of my students
um jillian on the right also employed
this technique with natural dyes so i
absolutely love that style you can then
take the die that you might have been
used for painting and you can thicken it
and do silk screen printing this is my
cat that i mentioned would be maybe in
and out of the screen now and then
this is one of my student kelsey doty's
designs you can see the silk screen
print there
this is bailey um hopkins henley she was
also in plant science um i've had a lot
of
plant science students come and take my
classes this was a
silk screen print that she did for her
final project a few years back
where she dyed the entire raw silk with
cochineal
beetles and then she silk screen printed
an
indigo design so it looks almost black
but it was blue when she printed it of
course the overlay of colors is going to
impact the color
you can use these naturally uh these
natural thickening agents to make
um the dye thick enough so when you pull
it through the screen
uh it's not gonna bleed everywhere right
so you wanna have the right thickness
viscosity
um so you can use uh sodium alginate
which is kind of brown seaweed you can
use gum tragacanth or guar gum
um and i i can also send along a list of
places where you can procure these
items i know it's not like you can't
just go to wegmans and buy
uh gum trigger camp but there are lots
of places online where you can get them
one of my favorite techniques is called
um contact dyeing and that it's one of
my favorite techniques because it is
really both sort of spontaneous um but
it also is one of the least
water intensive techniques around
because really you
you create pressure with the the dye
stuff
against the fiber and that pressure
either through hammering pounding or
just like tightly rolling it
and then steaming it requires very
little water it really just requires
steam
to set the color
so you can see here in this little video
that we're rolling up plant matter this
is one technique called bundling
where you roll the plant matter up into
the textile
and then essentially what we did was we
bound this big
sausage looking thing up with string as
tightly as we could
and then steamed it and this one wasn't
exactly too exciting because eucalyptus
and of course these little bits of
marigold they
end up yielding the same kind of color
um but it was still a very beautiful
color
uh some more exciting versions this is
cochineal that's hopi uh sunflower the
sunflower seeds when you
um die with this technique they often
yield a really beautiful purple but when
you try to vat dye with sunflowers they
tend to
yield more of a sort of brownish color
you though you can get
green to purple depending on ph again
lots of experimentation but the method
of dyeing will
uh you'll get different colors depending
on the method that you're using so again
lots of experimentation you can see
where i folded it down the middle
and used um colors on either end
uh this is one of the the ones that was
featured in the instagram post i think
this is hopidai
sunflower seeds and onion skins and you
can actually see the imprint of the
onion skin
on the right and then these are my yoga
clothes
uh some of the the yoga clothing that
i've been creating
over the last few years and um this is a
yoga top my
one of my collaborators locally is
audrey norberg she owns a farm called
plenty of posey she's both one of my
yoga students and one of my
wear testers for many years um the top
on the left
she wore to over 250 hot yoga classes
over like a year and a half long period
she's an avid hot yoga practitioner
and you can see that when i dyed it
initially it was the color on the right
and the effect of sweat heat
washing actually transformed the color
into you know more saddened color but
arguably deeper and darker so i find
this really interesting and i want to
work with some chemists in my department
to understand the impact of sweat
um and that's audrey there the shorts
are before
uh the wear and that's of course the top
that she's still wearing today
so and you can see uh some of the
the design elements here
and then this is um lily cocon she's
another
yoga practitioner who is kind enough to
model for me
some of the the pieces the purple that
you see is all hopi die sunflower seeds
and the yellow in these shorts is
actually from um dahlias
then the other technique i love is
hammering this is another kind of
contact die
where usually you put a piece of paper
over top of paper
or you know a light piece of fabric
and then you hammer down the material
while it's fresh
so you can get these really interesting
and experimental beautiful kinds of
ghostly images
um these are the leaves of hibiscus so i
was in hawaii last winter and this is a
bright bright magenta hibiscus actually
renders this more like purple
gray color and then lots of turmeric
i used which was fresh there and another
example this one using rose petals this
one was sadly not color fast and has
changed pretty dramatically over time
and then this is a little shot to show
you
sorry the noise of the hammering um yeah
my colleagues
are never very happy with me when we're
doing all this hammering in the human
ecology building that they very
generously put up with us
hammering away in our studio um to get
color this is
the collaboration that we did with sees
marjan
and what we did here we had to we had to
dye 18 yards of fabric in one day
um and so we set up a production line
where we had a
heavier weight more dented silk on the
bottom and a lighter weight more tinted
silk you can see we taped it down on top
and that way we could get the contact
eye on both sides so we weren't losing
the the top edge to the piece of paper
or whatever but instead we're
we're actually getting the mirror image
on the other um
piece of fabric so this was our uh
our way of of managing to get this the
fonz were on top and we were able to
still see the
the plants underneath which is really
important because you need to be able to
see where you're hitting and you also
need to use a rubber mallet
not a hammer because if you use a hammer
you run the risk of breaking a hole in
your fabric because it's um
you know pretty intense and you can see
that that's the lightweight just sort of
like
moving uh in the air just to give you a
sense of the sheer
sheerness of it um and then ultimately
you know we could go back and add more
if we needed to and then steaming to set
the colors
uh and then these are all the pieces
that were ended that were designed by
saunder lock who was the creative
director for csmarzen who
um then took all of the textiles that we
created and turn them into garments and
i'll just show you
a little bit here you can get a sense of
the um
the garments in motion in this slow
mo pick and i think i'm at the end of my
time
so i want to make sure i saw that there
were some things coming up in the chat
and i'm happy to start to answer those
questions
um i know that i know some of you
probably have to
to take off um but maybe i'll stop
sharing my screen and that way i can
start to answer some of these questions
and if others have questions please feel
free to
to speak up um wonderful well
an absolutely fascinating lecture denise
you know so many of us
work with plants in various ways but
we don't usually work with them in in
these applications so
it really is uh expanding for us
i see that there's a number of questions
that have to do with
mordants yes um so you were asking what
is the toxicity and health risks
so the toxicity and health risks will
depend on the mordant that's used
aluminum acetate and aluminum sulfate
are considered low risk
but something like a chrome or tin right
very very dangerous so
and again if you inhale anything it's
going to be dangerous so even if we call
aluminum acetate low risk if you're not
wearing a mask
and you're dumping it into a bucket and
the cloud is coming up and you breathe
in that's that's going to be very
bad for you oh gutta gutta is um
the question you would also ask the
question about what is gutta um
this is uh it's actually not natural
uh usually it's a petroleum byproduct it
feels really
um gummy actually and it's used in silk
painting to draw those white lines
um which creates a resist
to get it out you typically have to take
your textile to a dry cleaner
and like a not a non-toxic dry like the
toxic dry cleaner so
it's not an ideal um use allison asked
do we know what our ancestors used for
mordants
um so that's a great question and it
will depend on what part of the world
your ancestors were from
um in this region we we would imagine
that people were most likely using um
for the tannic acid for example
would have come from uh oh
it's it's eluding me now um
what is the one with the red cones that
we see everywhere
um um ruth to find a staghorn sumac
thank you um so we know sumac was used
to to get a lot of
tannic acid into the bath um but that
that's a really good question and
would require i think a lot a lot more
research into the specific
regions um uh okay
so uh when you get questions from uh
marcia what morden do you use with
eucalyptus
in eco printing so with eucalyptus
i i basically the mornings i use tend to
be whatever the
is the ideal mordant for the fiber type
so if i'm dying silk with eucalyptus i
would use
um i would use aluminum sulfate
but that said another technique that um
blossom schmidt one of my
my former students she has been
exploring
soaking different uh plants
leaves etc in uh ferrous sulfate and
iron
and like water that's that's got some
iron in it and then
putting those plants onto textiles and
then eco printing and she's gotten some
really amazing results
using iron um on the actual
uh um plant leaves and and whatnot
um gregory asked what is the potential
for local farmers to grow and sell dye
plants and or plant-based dyes is there
enough of a market
are large clothing companies interested
in natural dyes
the answer is yes there is a growing
market
our alumni some of you may know sarah
bellows
uh started a company called stoney creek
colors in tennessee
where she's working with um former
tobacco farmers or tobacco farmers to
convert their fields to indigo
she has a die house there in tennessee
um and so
there is a growing market we've seen
patagonia
all birds eileen fisher some of these
bigger large
you know fashion brands and smaller
fashion brands as well
are starting to experiment with natural
dyes
and so i think that there is a growing
market
um that said the bottleneck right now
is production right so we don't have die
houses
that are used to working with these
kinds of dyes either here
and abroad um so i
bring my students to india usually every
other year and we visited some natural
dye facilities but still relatively
small
scale i'm going to interrupt for just a
moment
and say that unfortunately i have to go
off and teach a class
but i invite all of you who don't have
immediate
commitments to stay with denise because
i see that there's
a number of additional questions and
again denise
to me this is an example of what is so
wonderful to
uh being at cornell is that we have
colleagues who are doing
such fascinating things so thank you so
much
thank you so much don for the invitation
and have a great class
thank you um and i'm happy to stay on
and talk to people and try to get
through
um the rest of these questions uh
do i have any favorite natural dye books
um
there has there has there are a lot of
really good books and i'd be happy to
put together a list
um but i i say
personally i've done most of my
education reading here and there but
really like trial and error
um on my own and just experimenting has
been
has been really my my method
but i i do have a library of books i'd
be happy to share some of the
titles with you do you know any
fermentation techniques to
increase dye color or color fastness
and how can this be used to enhance
results that is a great question ruby um
that is not something that i have
personally experimented with so i
i can't really say uh but i
know i mean uh indigo is a kind of
fermentation process
we know that with that particular dye
that sort of it needs to happen but
i would be curious to to know what
what others have been working with and
there are other folks doing that kind of
work
what if we have something that we think
might be a good die for example
petals on some ornamental with an
interesting color how can we test the
dye
um is there any rapid tests that let you
know whether something is good or not i
would say
the probably the easiest test to do at
home we have a testing lab in our
department but at home you could morton
your fabric dye it with
the material and then um you can do your
own washing test you could run it
through the washing machine
a few times or another thing that you
can do is like
uh stick it like with a piece of tape
stick it to a
south facing window uh that has gets a
lot of light
and then c you know put one swatch away
and
you know close it up in a dark place
tape a swatch to a bright window
and then in two weeks time see if
there's much of a difference or
you might see a huge difference in a
day's time
um so that will help you to understand
at home at least you know without any
fancy testing equipment
you can do your own lightness uh testing
and wash testing at home
um and i think uh oh ruby i will
yeah why don't you email me ruby and i
will put you in touch with some folks
at kansas state university they have an
amazing natural dye lab
and there are um when i visited uh
the agricultural uh university in tel
uh telangana uh they also have a natural
dye production facility where they're
doing
lots and lots of research so i'd be
happy to share that with you
um and thank you everyone for coming
today it was really nice
to be able to share this work and talk
with all of you
i had one last question oh yeah sure so
for
your uh dying with hammering that you
showed at the end
that was sent to new york city what kind
of like washing is done with that and
does it have to be dry cleaned and how
long would those colors fade
yeah so that's a really good question um
again the issue is around scalability so
basically what they ended up doing uh to
be honest
is they took the designs that we did and
then they digitized them
and they digitally printed them so what
ended up ultimately happening for like
the production
uh aspect of it because obviously like
hammering
by hand all of you know there could be a
way to
scale up the production of textiles like
that but
in their case they digitize them and
then digitally print for mass production
but for the fashion show
they use the original textiles um
the the trouble with greens in
particular those leaves so we used sage
we used um
japanese indigo leaves they look green
for a while
but it's not color fast and as that
chlorophyll starts it to shift it
and go away essentially you end up with
more of a brown over time so my guess is
in a year
everything that we saw was green will be
brown and that was
they understood that as part of the
process and
and ultimately ended up digitizing the
textiles to print them
that way which i you know is a little
bit disappointing
but you know they're trying to at least
you know experiment with these
techniques and hopefully we might see
ways of manufacturing at a larger scale
in the future
yeah thank you jonah any other
final questions
okay well thank you all it was nice to
meet you and thanks
for listening have a great day
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu